>> GET FACE ON IT.
>> THIS IS WHERE YOU WANT TO
PLAY AGAINST THE HAWKS GROUP.
A GOOD BELIEVE HE SCORED
IN UP THE ENTIRE
THE HAWKS ZIPPING IT AROUND.  O
BACK TO CENTRE ICE.
THIS IS A KIMMER FOR THE
HAWKS -- DECISION. .
CLAYTON KELLER WILL GO AFTERIT.
PLAYED
JONATHAN TOEWS, WHAT A BEAUTIFUL
PASS, SAUCER PASS.ACK IN THE DA
TRAVIS BOYD AGAIN UP.
STICKS IT ALONG THE NEAR BOARDSL
THE
CHALLENGE HERE, CHICAGO
INTERFERENCE.
THEY
DIDN'T SEE THE INSIDE THE ZONE.
SHOOTS IT WIDE. AGAIN.
COYOTES WITH 19 GOALS OVER THE
LAST A BATTLE THAT IS WON,
KANE GETS IT R MURPHY IN BEHIND
NET.
PLAYS
STROMAN STROME ACROSS.  LOOKING
WORK.
JOJO TO ALEX DEBRINCAT.
FAR SIDE, WITH IT.  JOHAN